Okay, this morning the market is moving
again. Big picture,
the NASDAQ is bouncing off of this high
right now. That looks really good in
terms of this big bearish candlestick
we're currently forming. Uh it's a
30-inut chart actually. I want a 15. Um,
and so
that's a nice resistance, but my
thinking is that because we already did
a big push and fail yesterday and this
overall kind of trend right here is
moving higher. Uh, and then looking at
the ES as well, is it stronger today? I
think it's more likely
that we bounce here and make new highs.
This is a daily ES chart. Um, we could,
you know, honestly do a retest here and
sell off. Like, this is a pretty big
bullish move up that
could use some kind of pullback. Um, so
either way though, I think it's it's
maybe looking for a long possibly if
that makes sense here in the next few
minutes
as there isn't really that much news and
we have a decent flush lower. ES is just
chop which doesn't look great for it.
Um, and you know, sometimes the market
will sell off and flip in the first 15
minutes, which is 7:45 for me right
here. Um,
so at the moment, I'm not going to buy
right here. It's I I can see it's it's
at like this tiny little swing. Um, but
that's, you know, that's not
where I like to put my money. I like to
use it on a larger level. Um, and then
oil is
just in a big sell-off right now. Uh,
again, it's not really at an area I'm
interested. It would need to come up to
at least here. I could I could push this
level a little bit higher. Um, but it's
a ways away from being touchable.
Gold looks like it's starting to top out
honestly, but again, it's it's in such a
a tight methodical range here
that it's not really super interesting
to me.
Um, again, you know, I like to see
a big move in one direction. kind of
like if we look at oil yesterday, not a
trade I caught because I was in another
one, but big move down chop reasons
reasons to buy. It was, you know, was it
was at a decent support level and then
shoots up. Um, and so we're not really
there. Um, natural gas, which is
something I've been recently looking at
a little bit more because it's got
pretty volatile moves.
It's kind of got a decent move up here.
um
pushing into
yesterday's kind of high. So there
there's potential there. But and and
natural gas is in a
bigger picture downtrend here. If I
actually pull this trend line down, um
that would be an interesting spot to
look for
a short.
But again, it's it's a waste from there.
So,
just kind of letting things play out
and seeing if we get opportunities this
morning.
Okay, that's a bit of a
We're basically at the 8:00 time for a
reversal.
The ES
is kind of at this uptrend
which I could see us bouncing off of. ES
looks a little stronger. I don't really
want to trade it just because it's
it's kind of choppy in a weird way. I
don't know. Even though it's the
stronger one, I don't really want to
trade it. Um I would rather trade the
NASDAQ because of the movement it has.
But I think I need like a head and
shoulders
or really clean double bottom.
Otherwise, there's a this is a this was
a lot of momentum going down. Like this
is a strong move. And so I don't want to
get in the way of that if it's going to
bounce here and then just keep going
lower.
Um,
it's in a good spot though. It could
totally bounce here.
Just seeing what happens. Downtrend's
broken.
It's clearly overextended to the
downside,
but I'm not going to take the first stab
up. That could just be a bait bait and
then it rips lower end.
The ES is so small. Like
these are ticks. It's moving. It's moved
a matter of points this morning.
This is like trading it yesterday. It's
pretty damn like there it was moving.
It was moving a lot more,
but it was still not crazy.
That's too aggressive. I'm not taking
that.
I'm I'm waiting a little longer than
normal here, but
ES is strong. I would not have gone long
right there though. That was at 09
09.
I need at least probably 20. Yeah.
What the was that?
Hello.
What random blip just happened?
That was crazy.
Okay, not going on a walk.
I want to see how it reacts after that
because that's doesn't seem methodical
and it seems like just
like someone just put in a fat sell
order.
Makes
me a little nervous. Make me want to go
smaller size
and almost just kind of see how
I mean on a five minute. What does this
look like on a five minute?
Looks pretty good in terms of
a retest. ES just
looks like a chopfest on a five minute.
This looks like it
could keep going higher.
I think if it made like another push
lower and retested this
and made an actual dough bottom.
I think I would like that cuz that wick
is just off of zero volume. I'm sure
if it makes a new push lower,
I need to stay. Yeah, I can't. I'd like
to go on my walk, but I need to stay
because this could be the final fake
lower.
If it gives this whole candlestick right
here,
that's pretty damn good looking.
And I would be down to enter in on that.
a little nerve-wracking, but again, I'm
I'm smaller size. It's a nice setup, but
it's not amazing.
Looking at the ES, it's well, still just
in it choppy range.
Just going to see how this plays out.
Okay, we are in
Put my target
again. I'm kind of nervous about this
one. It just doesn't feel great. The
setup's there. Big picture, we're at a
nice level. We've had a massive move
down.
I think the market, my inclination this
morning that the market was going to do
a pullback and push higher. The ES is
actually looking stronger.
I would say it's pretty choppy at this
point. I'm taking a trade at 8:30 which
is kind of like not a great hour but if
this candlestick finishes forming like
this on a five minute this looks clean
on a five yeah five minute candlestick
forming like that that looks super clean
to the upside
that we're likely to put in a bottom
here
and so
I really like this trade
But, you know, smaller size just because
I felt a little funky about things.
Um, and
we'll just see what happens here.
A little nervous. Just got to breathe
through it and let things play out.
Again, I'm smaller size.
It's okay. It doesn't have to be right
every time. I'd rather be wrong when I'm
smaller size. That's why I'm smaller
size because the setup's still great,
but it just
is a big bearish move and I'm not super
fan of it. And it's also long.
Longs are more difficult than shorts.
I think if it goes up to 1x here,
I'm going to move my stop up slightly.
Depending on what's going on, I think
just to break even, honestly.
Yeah, five minute looks so good. Just
look at a fivem minute. It makes me so
confident in the trade.
Five minute just looks super clean. Like
just a super clean
double bottom
off of yesterday.
It does feel like it wants to sell back
off.
But let's see what the ES looks like.
Actually, if we look at the ES, the ES
actually made a new high. That's really
good.
It's really good for this trade.
I mean, I think the market's going to
push up over the day
overall.
Like, looking at big picture, I think
we're just poised to push new highs.
Maybe not on the NASDAQ since it sold
off so hard,
but on a 15 minute, the ES just looks so
good to keep going higher.
Okay, now that this is breaking up,
I actually do just want to get out or
not get out.
Um, I am going to take off
I'm just going to take off five out of
nine at 2x.
Um, and then probably trail
the rest.
I'm just going to let this do its thing.
I If I think the market's going to rip
overnight,
not overnight, but
natural gas here.
I'm totally new to this, so I'm not
really looking to take a trade.
This is after
natural gas news popped
which was just natural gas inventories.
It's basically bouncing off of this
level. Oh, and this I mean that's still
pretty close to that downtrend line.
That's a nice spike in retest. You could
have shorted right there.
That looks pretty good. Oil is
downtrend. Gold is downtrend. Chop. I'm
glad I stayed out of that.
Interesting. Still just learning natural
gas, so not really watching it though.
Natural gas looks like it's about to
rip.
This thing looks clean. I wish I was
kind of watching it
like after that news jump in on this
lower high that it made
after it
really came up to this level. Sure, it
broke a little bit, but it came up and
touched this downtrend line.
And it's got clean chance to just rip
lower,
which is nice. Just easing into that
though.
Everything else is just
not interesting.
ES is
obviously would have been a better long
than the NASDAQ, but wasn't super clean.
Let's see where would I have entered in.
I entered in here
29. ES would have been 29 would have
been right here. Probably here after
gearing up this candle. Oh yeah.
So you would have been at
almost 3x already.
It's kind of a bummer. I'm basically at
1x right now on the NASDAQ.
Even with ES looking
kind of choppy, but you're just trading
I'd be trading.
I mean, I would only be trading two
contracts if I was doing 500 of risk.
Wait, I swear it just had 3x.
Okay. Okay. You'd be at you'd be at a
good 2x.
Oh, I see. It's it's jumpy because it's
s it's such
So small.
This was just way cleaner though. This
felt way cleaner.
But I That's a pretty good
go off of that.
As long as it hits this 2x. And then
I'll probably move this up to here
and just let it play out. I mean, I
think we have a good chance to rip the
rest of the thing.
you know,
and I can take the rest off like four
if we rip.
One, two,
seems unlikely we were all the way up
there, but we totally could.
Five minute.
That'd be giving up the whole move. I'd
want to get out at four
before we hit the open.
That would feel way better.
So, I need to get four. Take four off
here.
could get a reversal at 10
or nine nine around nine. We are hitting
that point and in terms of a 50%
pullback of this swing which is another
resistance area.
Do I have a
It's not what I want.
Okay, it's not what I want either.
This blue line right here is 50%
of this swing
and this high.
So, we could top out pretty much in this
area, which is basically where my 2x is.
So, we're coming up to nine o'clock, an
hour and a half after the market open,
which is definitely a
reversal window
potential.
But I I'm just going to I I I'm not
going to trail up here. I want to give
it more room. I'm not going to give it
more than break even
because ES is still at these highs. ES
could sell off there. I could see ES
selling out there. I'm not going to do
it because I'm in a long trade
obviously,
but I could see
things rivpping back down.
You know, if if
I'm trying to capture the big picture, I
don't want to manage on these smaller
swings. My big picture is the five
minute and that we're going to,
you know, even on a 15minute bounce off
these lows and continue higher. If we're
not, we're not. And that's that's fine.
Um because it's slowing down here and my
stops in a good spot. I'm just going to
go on a walk
with the dog.
There's not really much I can do. It's
either going to stop me out all the way
or it's going to come up here
and close out um
part of my trade. And at that point,
I'll be back. You know, it's only be
like 20 minutes.
Okay, back from the lock. Oh, sick.
Looks like I hit 2x on this. Um, what
does this look like?
Oh, wow. It barely bounced off of my
break even. That's sick. Um, so I want
to look at where this is now in terms of
trailing up a little bit more. I think
it just needs to I I don't think I can
really trail up
um at the moment. Like I could trail up
here,
you know, below that five minute
candlestick basically below this low.
But, you know, again, it's okay. I'm
capturing $100.
Um, not that big of a thing.
Yeah. And the ES here is close to actual
all-time highs on the ES. NASDAQ is way
lower than that. So, big picture,
um,
I definitely want to be out of this once
we get close up here because the
the na the ES is leading us to SP500 and
the NASDAQ is obviously a lagger and big
way.
Um,
bummer I'm not in on the ES cuz if I was
in, I would have been here
and this would have been clean into 3x
territory. But
that's how trading goes.
Just let this play out. I think I'm
going to get out the rest of 3x.
I'm probably not going to have it sit at
3x. Where is 3x on a fivem minute?
Right here. I mean, that's a nice spot.
It's likely to run into a little bit of
resistance here with that chop.
And frankly, I've got stuff I'd like to
get to today. Not a good reason to not
stay in a trade, though.
But on a five minutes still looks clean.
I'm going to go make food.
I think I'm going to take off two here
at 3x,
then trail the other two and see how I
feel about it.
Cuz this is still just kind of trending
up slowly,
but it's also just kind of slowing down.
like on a five minute of the ES. It's
it's looking a little bearish.
Obviously, like it can still totally
come into this trend line here.
And that's why I don't want to just get
out,
but it's just going to slowly trend
higher.
I would like to just kind of close out
here.
Yeah, I'm gonna move this up to 2x. I'm
not I'm not going to let it have a big
pullback on me at this point.
I don't think there's a point.
Okay, it looks like it's pulling back a
little.
It'd be a bummer to
have it get so close to that TP, but
It's okay. I was giving it room.
I don't want it to let it pull back.
It's It's showing to me that it's
starting to slow down and so it's time
to get out. I didn't know that this was
going to be the time to slow it slows
down.
And all I can do is go off of what my
read is. And my read is that the ES is
starting to top out. And that's the
driver of this. And you can see that the
NASDAQ is pulling back a lot faster.
And so if the ES pulls back just a
smidge more,
the NASDAQ's going to rip lower, like
all the way down here. And I'm not
holding down to this trend line, even
though that's what it's kind of moving
up. I'm not going to I'm not going to
wait that because the easy money is kind
of over from this swing. We've given
back up this basically this whole swing.
You know, obviously there's up here, but
That's And now it's like, okay, if it
bounces here, great. My stop's in a six
spot. I clearly have my stop in the
right spot. I'm not going to move it up
two ticks. It's not that big of a deal.
But if it bottoms there and and keeps
going up because yes, it is holding this
trend line.
Great. Punch new highs.
But that's definitely a change from this
slow grind tire.
Everything's just super slow now.
The news happening.
It's 10:00.
So there's not really
someone's talking at 11:30 15, but
yeah, trail up on this previous Oh, it's
five minute close right there. So
I will trail up. I'm going to do it.
It's hard.
Leave it where it was. It's not that
It's not going to make a difference.
Yes, it's still holding though.
Okay, closed out there.
I think it's a good call. This thing's
topping out. Still basically over 2x on
a trade I wasn't super confident in.
So happy with